this week on conflict zone I'm in Berlin
to talk to Ekaterina Zachariah foreign
minister of Bulgaria she is being among
the politician searching for a common EU
approach on the question of large-scale
migration now that a compromise has been
found is it a fair deal for everybody
and will the agreement lost
[Music]
a Catalina Sahaba
welcome to conflict zone your country
has just concluded six months in the
presidency of the EU the most pressing
was and is still migration now there is
a deal on this but it is very light on
details isn't it I think there are many
challenging during our presidency and
migration fortunately is the most
divided topics high very highly you
agenda more than three years and what we
try to do during our presidency is to
propose compromises but you didn't six
yeah but we are really we are who are
really close to do this and to succeed
is refers to control center for asylum
seekers on European territory the
decision of some outside yeah the
decision to build these will be
voluntary let's be honest no one will
volunteer for that it's also inside
inside and outside inside and outside
yeah it is a what survive inside no
nobody wants to do it even you decided
that there are some existing and what
what is the Bulgarian position of this I
was big now after the presidency can
speak much small out Bulgarian position
of Bulgaria proposal there are three
peers our opinion and three dimensions
how to say to solve this with a long
long perspective manner not just crisis
after crisis after crisis and we wasn't
prepared for the first Christ not one of
the European members remarried their
crisis in the world everybody knew that
their crisis and you know it's also for
some crisis responsible so naivety about
what you know okay
is Europe responsible for some crisis
maybe maybe partially yes and the
probable getting proposal for double
integration is not 203 years
we in crisis or not and took us three
years to take decision to sign for
example your Turkish agreement which
actually decrease 89 percent the
pressure of the border but let's talk
about that you know so these are these
are old solutions we just had a summit
European summit is Bulgaria willing to
build an asylum Center like that will
you volunteer we don't
so everybody's saying no so what does it
mean everybody is saying no everybody
decided Bulgaria also decided the last
text so what does it mean if you say no
we external border as you know and we
protect our external border extremely
good not our European Union external
border and we have centers and we
register actually we have registered and
registered all refugees that cross our
border so according to the Dublin
regulation existing one and what
happened actually if their refugee they
have to see to find the first safety
place but most of those people don't
want to stay in Bulgaria they don't want
to stay in Greece they don't stay in
Italy even but this has perhaps made you
talk about their country in Europe which
is not the case that we can yeah we will
talk about that why refugees don't want
to stay in Bulgaria but let's let's
continue let's let's talk about the
control centers because this is a very
important issue these processing centers
are closed and controlled that's the
idea right
the process is Center and in the
beginning there are hotspots detention
centers now we call them processing
processing but they are closed in
control that we are and that two types
of this food clothes control for the
people who don't actually have received
advance who is really allowed and
not allowed basically a closed
processing center is like a prison for
escaping people many of them barely
survived the journey to Europe it that
what you want
closed centers first of all what we want
is to close our external border is not
normal
everybody who want to come to live in
Europe and to look for better life which
is normal well for the people who can
cross illegal border and it's nice where
we don't speak about these ones who want
to have a better life we are speaking
and talking about these ones who have to
escape like Syrians because there is war
in Syria unfortunately still or eight
years actually already that's why and
the asylum legal rights are not to
compare with these people who want to
have a better life so really let's talk
about these ones so let's make necessary
between the refugees and illegal
migration yes unfortunately what we see
in Europe that people stop to make these
differences because of many legal
migrants that are still coming can
continue to come in Europe and this is
the problem even in Bulgaria but not
only in Bulgaria I just spoke with with
the Germans girlfriends and
unfortunately even in Germany the people
stopped to make this difference refugee
and illegal migration explain to their
population that European politicians
wants to explain to their population the
opposite that the refugee crisis is a
crisis not because refugees are coming I
mean another part of the deal but it was
it is also absolutely different 2012 13
14 15 ninety percent from the people who
cross for the European border where
refugees and now it's not that not not
like that but you have to control if you
then you have to have a legal it doesn't
either go make migrants yes but you have
however regardless of that remark there
is a legal process which has to be done
another part of the deal with which your
Prime Minister Louis of has expressed
support
for is the so-called disembarkation
platforms in North Africa you agree with
what we what we say yeah this is
Bulgarian position what we support is
three pillars measures and they cannot
work separate so one not one of them
it's enough I understood one is North
Africa and this implication clicked so
what is what is our opinion and this is
in this declaration actually European
declaration its European leaders
declaration achieved after hours and
hours of discussion and it's gross
external borders but so leader with the
external borders countries because we
yes okay we managed to tackle ourselves
but it's much more difficult for Greece
and Spain but we should not forget also
Bulgaria Cyprus Malta and so on and so
forth also when we talk about solidarity
is it solid or only the external borders
country to accept all the refugees or
illegal migrants that want to come in
Europe but you know what is not so you
know it's not foreigner during we are
talking about that North African states
have already rejected this idea there is
not one North African state who said
Here I am we are helping Europe but we
have to support also them too of course
through this Africa transform that we
created and if you see the datas 95
percent decreasing of of migrants and
refugees illegal migrants and refugees
since the measures that we took since
signing the Turkish you a statement
agreement since creating can develop an
African trust fund I'm so very sorry
again you are telling to your population
into the Europeans that this implication
platforms will be North Africa there is
not one state who is saying we have we
agree on that we continue we continue to
talk with them and that's why one of the
most important pillar of this is
external peer we have to continue to
work with those country to support them
and it's not only not North Africa
country let's be frank we talked about
Sahel region about corner of Africa
region we talk about the body
oh [ __ ] with Libya do you support Libya
we have to make you support this idea
yes we support this a Libya does not
have a functioning government Lib is
very complicated situation they have two
governments as you know but very
difficult board to control and to
negotiate yeah we the negotiate with
geniu laws smugglers criminals which are
not there now to negotiate with the
smugglers but your neighbor with
governments without any part if we know
there is an official government but
unfortunately okay yes in power no AHA
its I would not say like this I'm not
agreeing with you are they don't be as
powerful as you are just saying you
wouldn't have problems criminals they
can't take care in their own country my
experts are yes it is possible
sorry but what we do if you continue to
accept the legal migration actually we
support smugglers and criminals who
don't care about those people and just
take the money and push them in the
water said I don't care about you and
not only in the water in the tracks too
so we have to tackle and we have to stop
this illegal cross-border because true
continuing support of this illegal
crossing we actually support the
smugglers but face in our flat your
solutions so we will not negotiate with
smugglers and traffickers but you're
negotiating with Libya oh this Oh deep
what you saying that all Libyans as
martyrs no the government is not a
powerful and you know this as you know
that the North African they don't they
are not interested to negotiate with
Europe you know they have your challenge
we negotiate a new frustrations no
you're not right we negotiate and we
actually work very in close cooperation
with UN and with international
organization of migrants and we have
actually a huge successes so let's be
frank
we are not there where we have to be on
join commonly
we are really very close but we have a
huge difference since ninety since 200
in the 2015 so we have 95% decreasing of
illegal crossing borders and these are
the facts let's have a look at
Bulgaria's record you have taken in a
few refugees the Bulgarian Helsinki
Committee human rights NGO based in the
capital Sofia says quote the situation
of zero integration of refugees in
Bulgaria has been going on for fourth
year in a row zero integration and then
you are stunned that refugees want to
live to leave Bulgaria you know I think
that of course I know these reports
I'm not agree with everything what is
written there so the fact that all the
people that come and absolutely free
with politicians but not only in
different organisation to see what
happening in our border it's many
speculation what we do with the refugees
but it's proven that it's not real its
objective now as a Turkish according to
the EU Turkish statement actually they
obliged if they try to legal
cross-border to take this in to send
them back in Turkey so we don't we don't
open Yun's let's take the amnesty World
Report 2017 they say quo the necessary
services were not provided to migrants
and refugees including to unaccompanied
children it documents the case from
February for example last year a Syrian
family had been granted humanitarian
status in Bulgaria the major in the town
of Aileen Palin said quote Muslim from
Syria will not welcome yeah a truce is
missing area doesn't want to host
refugees I say that not only Bulgaria
doesn't want to host the refugees it we
have to take care for the refugees but
see what happened and that's why I
started with this we stopped to do a
difference between migrants and illegal
illegal migrants and refugees beyond
them and this is because of when we want
to tackle if we think that we can tackle
is emit more populism it's wrong
approach
and what is decision now
all the European member states to build
fancies among us Schengen don't work is
it isn't it better to protect our sterno
borders and to create if for the
countries who want migrants because they
need working forces to create a legal
program for migration because actually
we save 650,000 people from death okay
so let me continue my opinion if you
also miss recent Bulgarian opinion if we
want to tackle and to save people's life
actually to tackle with illegal
migration to traffic ins smugglers and
those criminals we have to stop illegal
crossing borders so the European Union I
got refugee you don't try to cross the
legal border
if you think that according to the to
the Convention for Refugees you are
refugee you have to go into a refugee
this is my appeal for asylum seeker I
understood so let's talk about something
else you seem to have no problem with
the Bulgarian national movement with
according to a report by the Council of
Europe is quote notorious for
systematically propagating hatred
against neighboring people in the
Balkans as well as anti gypsy propaganda
it's a coalition partner yes we have
coalition partner and we have different
opinions but we have really very clear
coalition agreement that it's your power
with this party another example of this
hatred is coming from the Deputy Prime
Minister you Deputy Prime Minister
semyonov he was found guilty of hate
speech against Roma he's still deputy
minister and you don't say anything
Deputy Prime Minister and you don't say
anything
I was not agreed with this opinion with
different political parties I see that
in Germany in Germany that they have a
different position of migration anybody
is talking like that about minorities
and German government another quote
let's listen to your deputy prime
minister he said in the Bulgarian I'm
not agree with his opinion Roma people
are Arabic we have to try to integrate
them but if we walk about right and we
try to integrate them but if we
integrate now Roma
to Deputy Prime Minister Alma 12% of our
assumption ferocious humanoids demanding
wages about labor demanding sick leave
benefits without being sick child
benefits for children that play outside
with the street pigs and maternity
benefits for woman with the instincts of
Street [ __ ] this is your Deputy Prime
Minister you are still in a coalition
with such a man
we are and actually since he this was
during his pre-election campaign he is
in he is in the government he absolutely
changed his approach to the problem to
responsible you posed with hot sugar I
know this is a race is this a racist
statement yes or no for the gypsies it
was a racist statement but so you are
you on government with a racist party
and the Prophet I mean how is everything
it was originally election campaign and
I was not agree with what he just what
he was said and since we are in the
government we have absolutely clear
position that is stick to the European
values and also conventions that we
signed and joint and if we continue to
be blind that illegal migration it's a
huge problem and in every European
citizen we are not talking about
migration we do worse the fact is the
fact is that most of them we have six
point eight percent unemployment five
point eight percent in bubble for the
hilly area and most is salty people
unknown point people unfortunately from
so this is what is what is what we do
what we do we create a special program
to oblige the Roma's to send the
children in the schools and in the
kindergarten to give them a future so we
put a lot of efforts and government
support there Bulgaria's here the upper
garius we have
Bulgarians with trauma origin we have
also 12% of beginners with Turkish
origin so and we are proud we are proud
with ethnic tolerance and we never
compare with other Balkans country
didn't have tension between the
different people we didn't have tension
between the so many people said a lot of
things before elect it's not many people
know many people in Europe also say a
lot of people many things before
elections not only in Bulgaria after
elections enough today to join the
government it's a different position
okay
ever never in our history we have
tension between the Bulgarians with
baguette in origin and Bulgaria sweeter
so we are proud of this okay you are
also proud about your important
relationship with Russia you have a good
relationship with Russia we have a good
relationship with Russia but we
absolutely stick to the European
principles and we mentioned a point
Bulgaria is the best friend of Russia
Bulgaria stop South Stream will Gators
start up a nuclear power ballon a what
about another house your position about
sanctions and also pour gasoline Drupal
is project so we are absolutely Toronto
European Paris are you in favor for the
sanctions against Russia's just the
European leaders took decision to
continue the sanctions you are obviously
Bulgaria support were supported for this
and these are sanctions not again
Russians is sanctions it's our red lines
about Russia behavior to Ukraine and to
creamier so but what's about Ukraine
what's about the crime Crimea crisis
what's about Syria what's your opinion
about Vladimir Putin and his policy body
milk protein obviously want to be very
strong men and and for example for for
Crimea absolutely it's unacceptable and
non country can just decide to take this
is my part not stick to the to the to
the international rules and values for
Syria will condemn Russia's
yeah I should behave in Ukraine for for
Syria for example and what we can do
together with with Russia we have to
work to
with Russia on European level not only
also on bilateral level to tackle for
example terrorism to try to solve the
crisis in Syria to North Korea but you
have very deep end with girls very
dependent on Russia yes yes Russia gets
more lessened right
modern only but around 92 let's talk
about that so it's a it's a dependent on
Russia guest but we work on on diversity
and what what what actually happen I
talk a lot a little bit more about gas
supplies we start South Stream and some
of the member state developed a North
stream - so what we what what we are we
will be dependent on Russian Turkey at
the same time because if we stop
supplies through North at the same time
at the same time of your script once a
multi-blade we think that it's important
for Bulgaria to have also to develop own
routes of gas supply yeah me too are you
going to build a nuclear power plant
with Russia Rose Otto it makes you even
more dependent from Russia we stop
Helena but now we paid a billions for
two reactors that are like monuments and
we want to develop this project as
private project without dependency so we
look for private investments there are
different candidates who still didn't
chose a candidate so sorry mister for us
it's important mr. bubbly so mr. Prosise
off said that it is a good idea to
restart the project yeah we try to find
investor because we pay a billion from
our taxpayers for two reactors that sit
like a monuments and we will look
private investment they are interesting
some private investor from China that
they interested given from United States
they are coming from Russia so we didn't
chose but we will negotiate let's talk
it lands on the when negotiations every
time if is if we speak about Russia
let's talk about corruption because this
is also one of your responsibilities
you are deputy prime minister in charge
of judicial reform and this and it's
2017 report on the fight against
corruption and organized crime Bulgaria
the EU talked about and quote
unpredictable legislative decision
making process and suggested your
government has rolled back earlier
reforms which is this report that you
read which here it is the report of the
EU which year 2017 you know the report
from 770 reporter sees 2017 perception
said the same thing they said that
corruption is increasing your own
president said it just a few weeks ago
there is a lot of talking about
corruption in Bulgaria it's your
president but I think too little is
being done why does he say that you know
first reports from 2017 it was in autumn
before and then the last one it was the
last one said that we are absolutely
moving very well through this CVM
mechanism that we have and we just adopt
and create in the beginning of 2018 the
anti-corruption body which actually
already have four successes so let's
give a chance to this body to say
there's a half years in you to global
financial integrity washington-based
Research Organisation says every year
the country losses don't win if you say
you know 22 let's talk with numbers
because they're much more precise now
sometimes we have almost 4% economic
growth we have 7.5 billion trade with
Germany and increasing investment from
Germany and German investors are feeling
very well for example the biggest
foreign foreign investor in Bulgaria is
Netherlands so if the business feel well
does mean that there is no so dark
picture in Bulgaria of course we have
problems with corruption and you want to
tackle corruption not because of
Brussels and not because of transparency
International or not because of Hague or
Berlin or Paris we think that we have
problems and we work to tackle these
problems but it's not so dark and if you
see actually for example for because our
Prime Minister very like I was listening
to mangling smuggling of cigarettes we
are less than 8% compared with other
member states
what is this is it corrupt they're
corrupt of course we have problems with
corruption allowed in IDs when I'm late
we have no problems we have problems
with corruption and we don't deny this
but we work to tackle this and we are
much better compared with what was 5
foot a Katerina Sahara thank you very
much for being on conflict so it was a
pleasure to thank you thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]